mashed potatoes are a must especially
when it comes to the holidays it's
basically the side dish that keeps on
giving am i right
surprisingly there are quite a few
mistakes when it comes to mastering the
art of mashed potatoes we went through
about 20 pounds of potatoes to bring you
the ultimate creamy super smooth mashed
potatoes they're seriously so good
you're going to want to lick the plate
there's two types of potatoes starchy
and waxy for mashed potatoes you want a
starchy potato a potato with higher
starch and low moisture will yield a
fluffier inside we're using yukon gold
potatoes they're actually somewhere in
between a starchy and a waxy potato
they're harder to over mash and have a
foolproof creamy texture we're going to
peel the potatoes before boiling some
people like to leave the skin on their
mashed potatoes which creates a little
bit more texture but for really creamy
silky smooth mashed potatoes with a
uniform texture it's going to work a lot
better with the skin off
quick tip to keep your potatoes from
discoloring and oxidizing as they sit
out place them in a bowl of cold water
while you work
after you've filled your potatoes cut
them into one-inch cubes this way
they're going to cook more quickly and
evenly
add your potatoes to a pot of cold water
and add a very generous pinch of salt
this is going to help build the layers
of flavor as the potatoes cook which
means you'll need less salt down the
line
now we're going to bring the potatoes to
a soft boil over high heat
once you've reached a soft boil reduce
the heat to low and simmer for about 12
minutes you'll know your potatoes are
ready for mashing when they're fork
tender go ahead and remove the pot from
the heat and drain the potatoes through
a colander at this point you're actually
going to place the potatoes back in the
pot over medium-high heat and stir them
around for two to three minutes that's
just going to release any excess
moisture at the end of this the potatoes
should be super dry
when it comes to mashed potatoes most
people use a potato masher or even a
fork some people use a potato ricer for
a more uniform texture which we're also
really big fans of if you don't have any
of those tools and want to get a similar
result you can use a fine mesh sieve
place the boiled potatoes in the sieve
and use a spatula to gently push them
down i'm not gonna lie this definitely
takes more muscle and is more time
consuming but the potatoes are gonna be
so silky smooth and beautiful it's
really worth the effort whatever you do
do not use a food processor or a hand
mixer this is going to overwork the
potatoes creating a gummy like paste and
let's be real no one wants that now it
wouldn't be mashed potatoes without
adding some butter you want to use
unsalted butter because it allows you to
control the amount of salt in your
mashed potatoes we made so many
variations of mashed potatoes and taste
tested all of them we tried cold butter
milk melted butter sour cream cream
cheese heavy cream and after all that we
decided to stick with melted butter and
heavy cream while some people do like
sour cream and cream cheese we found
that the flavor really stood out and
took away from that uniform consistency
and texture that we were looking for
quick tip you always want to add your
butter before adding any cream or milk
this is going to ensure that the texture
of the potato remains firm before being
softened by all that cream if you add
your butter and your cream all at once
it's going to create this really soupy
texture whereas if you go gradually
it'll be nice and smooth and creamy so
remember how we talked about building
flavors this is another time where
you're gonna season it with salt add
your heavy cream to a small saucepan
over medium-high heat this is also the
moment when you can enhance the flavor
of your mashed potatoes we're going to
add some rosemary sprigs and garlic but
you can get creative with other herbs
and ingredients as well bring the heavy
cream mixture to a simmer once it's
simmering for a few minutes and that
cream is getting really infused with
flavor you're going to strain out the
garlic and the rosemary through a sieve
and then add just the cream to the
potatoes little by little until they're
fully incorporated
remember if you add all the heavy cream
at once it's just going to become a
soupy mess
as you fold the heavy cream into the
mashed potatoes you're going to see this
really smooth texture start to come
together
i mean it's so beautiful
it's that easy your potatoes are finally
ready to serve so because it's tasty
we're going to top it with more butter
we're also going to add some freshly
ground black pepper some chives you can
really experiment with your toppings but
this is a pretty classic preparation
or if it's that special time of year
pass the gravy baby
i mean come on what's not to love
and there you have it the creamiest
mashed potatoes you've ever laid eyes on
or in our case are taste buds
it's like luscious
they're really they're luscious mashed
potatoes they're luscious that's the
only way to describe them
kind of sexy like have we i mean
we ate so many of them
it's insane so many